we've spoken in the past to psychiatry
professor dr. John Gartner on the show
about his concerns regarding Donald
Trump's mental state and as I mentioned
to you before there is another
psychiatrist dr. bandy Lee who is
increasingly talking about what appears
to be something very wrong with the
President of the United States dr. bandy
Lee is a forensic psychiatrist at Yale's
School of Medicine also president of the
world mental health coalition and dr.
Lee has written a piece after Donald
Trump's assassination of Iranian leader
Kassim Soleimani that we should be
looking at very closely because it's so
disturbing and immediately you know the
the the military explanation the
strategic explanations of the Soleimani
assassination made no sense and many of
us went to trump wants to distract from
impeachment from wants to help himself
get reelected in 2020 believes that
assassinating Kassim soleimani may help
him achieve that goal but there's
another angle to this and what dr. bandy
Lee says is that narcissistic madman is
essentially what explains what we are
seeing from Donald Trump here check this
out from dr. Lee's piece so what is
happening with the president it is what
my esteemed colleague and former
director of a division at the National
Institute of Mental Health dr. John
Zinner has warned about narcissistic
rage he joined me in leading the
petition to Congress for he believed too
that while impeachment was important
Donald Trump had the real potential to
become even more evermore dangerous as
his condition progressed as a threat to
the safety of our nation short of his
sole command over nuclear weapons there
were many other dangers he can pose by
the use fueled by rage of his assumed
absolute executive authority and by the
loyalists who serve him and as dr. Lee
goes on to explain this further it is a
spitting image of Donald Trump
particularly analyzed in the context of
the Soleimani assassination
check this out quote anyone who has seen
attacks of narcissistic rage knows it
can be brutal and destructive the
afflicted person outraged at the
deprivation of the adulation to which
feels entitled becomes blind to other
concerns such as the safety of others or
the self upon collapse of one's
grandiose image which required adoration
to buttress one is no longer capable of
repressing the painful feelings of
inferiority and inadequacy that
resurface this experience is more
menacing than any existential threat
could be access to weapons or war-making
power in such a state is extremely
dangerous for they become highly
attractive as a means of restoration
mistakes of the past such as aggression
in the Middle East are likely to repeat
in more serious form rather than be
avoided
this is Donald Trump period and the
things that are the thing that's
starting to get awkward is that we know
there are people in Donald Trump's
cabinet and in the Senate that know that
this is true they are sort of in this
Russian Roulette do you fire the gun and
maybe get another conservative judge
confirmed while Donald Trump is acting
wacky or just Trump pull the trigger in
a serious way up to and including even
the topic of nuclear war seemed to be a
possibility
earlier this week although not in a
serious manner this is a good time to
mention there are a ton of people who
are so desensitized to the way that
Donald Trump typically behaves I talked
about this yesterday they saw Donald
Trump's speech on Iran two days ago and
because Trump merely lied and stuck to
the prompter instead of doing his usual
antics a lot of people are saying wow
what a presidential speech by Donald
Trump he seems completely fine Donald
Trump giving one speech that's not
completely unhinged should not make us
forget all of the things he's done and
said which gets us back to Republicans
many Republicans the ones that know the
degree of absurdity that is Donald Trump
once Donald Trump is gone the ones whose
careers out lived from presidency
they're immediately going to either
pretend that Trump never happened or
that they never really liked Trump they
weren't really with them to begin with
others will blame things that happened
under Trump's watch either on Obama or
on whoever follows Donald Trump if the
person who follows Donald Trump is a
Democrat Republicans have many reasons
to keep Donald
in office right now some are getting
their stuff done while Donald Trump goes
crazy others are themselves compromised
because in the end when the rubber meets
the road you have a completely unhinged
ignorant president who assassinates an
Iranian leader without the congressional
authorization he claimed presidents need
and they rally around him other than
Mike Lee and start their defenses with
well this guy was no angel soleimani was
a bad guy there's lots of bad guys out
there they are part of the problem every
time they run interference for Trump
with those talking points because they
that is a completely different
discussion who's bad is a very different
discussion than what Donald Trump did
without congressional authorization to
Kaseem soleimani
and particularly when you consider the
question of why he did it not because of
any actual national security imperative
we've seen the razor-thin bogus
justification from the administration
but to take attention away from
impeachment and also because he believes
on some level that it will help bolster
his shot at re-election in November of
2020 we can't let it continue make sure
you're following us on Instagram for
more on this and other stories from
today's show at David Pakman show quick
break back after this